ap ap
[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir demain mardi sera une journée
capitale pour le retour de notre pays à
la normale après trois semaines de
conflit et de grève nous vous
présenterons en images la synthèse des
différentes négociations de ce lundi de
pentecôte dont la principale a été celle
portant sur la sncf négociations qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas encore terminée
quelle qu'en soit l'issue
on sait que le travail reprendra demain
dans un certain nombre de secteurs en
particulier la banque et la sécurité
sociale et que dans un plus grand nombre
d'entreprises les travailleurs seront
appelés à se prononcer sur la reprise du
travail mais au delà des grèves les yeux
se tournent vers les élections
législatives du 23 juin nous ferons le
point sur les travaux des différentes
formations de la majorité et de
l'opposition
au chapitre international l'information
du jour c'est l'arrivée à paris d'un
nouveau négociateur nord-vietnamiens
d'un rang très élevé les informations
générales nous retiendrons surtout la
bagarre de belleville et le
malencontreux accident de tabarly dans
la course transatlantique
avant de laisser la place aux images je
voudrais vous dire un mot de notre
maison
la situation d'ensemble à l'eau rpf fera
l'objet d'une déclaration au nom du
gouvernement de monsieur yves guéna
ministre de l'information
cette déclaration sera diffusé à prêter
les soirs un certain nombre de mesures
personnelles vienne d'autre part
d'intervenir à la rtf monsieur pierre de
boisdeffre a quitté ses fonctions à la
direction de la radiodiffusion monsieur
emile biasini a remis sa démission de
directeur de la télévision
quant à monsieur edouard sabliers il
quitte la direction de l'actualité
télévisée les journalistes et
techniciens qui sous sa direction
on a tenu le journal télévisé pendant la
période difficile que vient de traverser
le pays tienne a assuré edouard sablier
de leur sympathie et de leur confiance
je vous invite maintenant à regarder tes
les soirs en commençant par l'actualité
politique
[Musique]